trump and biden gaff all over each other
as the polls titan michelle obama says
the quiet part out loud
and we explore why some leftists are now
claiming that two plus two equals five
like actually i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let others track what you do keep
yourself safe at expressvpn.com
ben well i will say that this campaign
it's beginning to tighten the polls are
showing that it's beginning to tighten
just a little bit there's several polls
out in the last week that showed that
president trump is within a national
striking distance of
joe biden which is good news because you
would assume that trump is probably
going to lose the popular vote he could
lose the popular vote by up to four
points
and still win the election if the votes
happen in the wrong places for joe biden
if they all happen in california or
massachusetts or new york or washington
dc
in the swing states joe biden still has
a pretty solid lead in a lot of these
various states but
he is not very far above where hillary
clinton was in many of these states
florida he's pretty well ahead of the
pace set by hillary clinton but he's
well behind hillary clinton
where she was in pennsylvania he's well
behind where she was at this time in
places like michigan
which suggests that this election ain't
quite over yet now we are being deprived
of the full glory
and majesty of the clash of intellectual
titans that is going on between
president trump and joe biden
right now and it is it would be
astonishing to watch them both on the
campaign trail
a man who probably cannot stay awake for
more than about 37 minutes at a time
versus a man who cannot stay focused for
more than about 47 seconds at a time
and it is amusing to watch the two of
them go at it i'm looking forward to the
debates i've said before
that the debates i think probably will
happen that won't happen with a crowd
which is a pity because that's president
trump's wheelhouse
when president trump has a crowd he
plays to the crowd in ways that
no one outside of the comic community
would do i saw a clip of shane gillis
the comedian
back from march talking about debates
with trump and he said trump is
basically a stand-up comedian
and he would just bury you on stage like
all these comedians who go out there
and they say things like he's a bad
orange man he's so bad trump would bury
them if you were next on stage because
that really is his specialty
is being a jerk in public to people so
that would be a disadvantage
for joe biden but we still have the
somewhat muted pleasure
of watching these two candidates just
gaff regularly now the difference
between how the media treat the gaffs
that's what's truly astonishing so trump
right now is making a lot of gaffes that
don't go to substance
he's making a lot of gaps that are kind
of funny to to look at but don't really
mean anything in the long run so you saw
the other day he said about
yosemite like the national park he
called it yes
and everybody went nuts because that's
hilarious i mean it is
it's it's it's what i say to my fellow
jews right as we were arriving at shul
we're walking into we're walking into
synagogue i'm like yo semi like yeah
what's up with you
but you know is that like a gaffe with
content usually what a gaff is it's a
revealing moment where you know
something more about the candidate than
you otherwise would
a gaf is something that is revealing
it's not just a male prop
and right now most of the gaffs that
trump is making are male props
most of the gaffes that joe biden is
making go to two things one
the fact that he is increasingly senile
and two the fact that he's kind of a
little bit racist
he keeps making these weird gaffes with
black americans
where he just says stuff that if
republicans said it they'd be toast
they'd be trashed
right you remember that just a few weeks
back he said to a
black commentator it was charlemagne the
god he said you ain't black
if you don't vote for joe biden which is
patently crazy
like joe biden being the adjudicator of
blackness is pretty insane that's a real
white dude that's a real white dude who
used to hang out with segregationists
and do legislation with them
so that's kind of strange and the media
just kind of it was it was a story for a
moment and then it sort of got glossed
over
well joe biden is making exactly those
kind of gaps pretty much every day
and the media are just glossing over
them the difference in media treatment
truly is amazing so let's begin with
some of trump's guests these are the
ones that are taking top headline
and they really are taking top headline
in a pretty serious way
i i will say i'm kind of amazed by the
coverage of the various gaffs
over at matt drudge's website um matt
drudge
was one of the big cheerleaders for
trump i mean in 2016 there is no
question that drudge wanted trump to win
he was spending enormous amounts of
energy on his page
focusing in on trump and how trump was
sucking up all the attention
trump was a click machine for drudge now
drudge really doesn't cover the gaps
that biden does in a very significant
way
but any gaff that trump commits he's
covering in a really really significant
way i don't know what trump did to him
or whether
manish is spending less time on the site
i i really don't know what's going on
over at drudge report but you can see
that the coverage over at drudge
honestly it mirrors more of the coverage
at cnn than it does the coverage over at
fox news which is kind of a shocker
because
drudge used to be much more in sort of
the fox news column politically in any
case
here's an example so yesterday president
trump was doing a speech
and he was talking about joe biden and
the fact that joe biden's agenda is
anti-religious
now there's some truth to this okay joe
biden supports the so-called equality
act it is hr1 that is a bill that is
pushed by democrats that essentially
says that religious institutions
should be forced to violate their own
religious precepts in order to
maintain quote unquote equal treatment
for lgbt
people so you have to have a priest
who's transgender in your church
the equality act basically says that if
you're a religious business owner you
will now be mandated
in any business that you are including
religious businesses you will be
mandated
to abide by social leftist it goes even
further than the recent supreme court
case which declared that
in places of employment the civil rights
act protects transgender people
it actually because there's still
ministerial exceptions and religious
school exceptions the equality act
doesn't do any of that
okay so president trump was going after
joe biden and his anti-religious agenda
and while he was riffing he said that
joe biden was going to hurt god
and now that that really is not a
particularly revealing gaffe like
i don't think that trump actually thinks
that joe biden is going to start hurling
spears at god or something or that if he
did it would be particularly effective
it was just trump riffing because that's
what trump does so here's trump doing
this yesterday he got all sorts of
attention
you will have a crash in the markets
because he's going to double and triple
your taxes
he's going to do things that nobody ever
would ever think even
possible because he's following the
radical left
agenda take away your guns
destroy your second amendment no
religion know
anything hurt the bible hurt god
he's against god he's against guns
he's against energy our kind of energy
okay so obviously trump is riffing there
and it's a very crude way of saying that
his agenda is
anti-religious which again is true and
barack obama's agenda was also
anti-religious barack obama was the man
who campaigned in 2008 telling his
donors in san francisco
that only bitter clingers clinging to
god and guns and religion were the
people who were standing between him and
victory
so that that is not you know it's not a
major gaffe seriously like
i guess there's the implication that
that trump because he's not a
particularly religious person he's
saying things that religious people
would never say like as a religious
person i never said that someone
is capable of hurting god god ain't
capable of being hurt if you're a
religious person
you're like well that's weird because
god is the master of the universe and
the creator all things so i'm pretty
sure that joe biden can't hurt him
still is that like a major gaff no it's
kendra it's mildly revealing of the fact
that trump
doesn't know much about religion which
is true it's mildly revealing of the
fact that trump speaks in like very
dumbed down terms which of course is
true
but is it a seriously revealing thing
not really big banner headline over on
drudge trump claims god on his side
okay honestly that no he claimed that
that's actually not what he claimed what
he claimed
is that joe biden opposes religious
people which is kind of true
okay like i think that's what he's
saying i don't think that donald trump
is sitting there going
god loves me and god hates job hyden i i
don't think that that is actually the
case
and the media immediately swivel into
how dare trump say this about a
practicing catholic never remind the
fact that there are catholic priests who
will not give communion to joe biden
because he is pro-abortion now
and joe biden has switched his positions
on abortion several times
moving ever more in the pro-abortion
direction
right for he he's a practicing catholic
the way that nancy pelosi is a
practicing catholic which is to say they
violate
religious scripture on a fairly regular
basis but the media's angle was
how dare trump say something like it was
a big revealing gaffe for trump
in a second we'll go through trump's
other gaffes and then we'll get to joe
biden's gaps which are being covered for
full scale by the media it's pretty
insane first
let's talk about the fact that right now
a lot of us need to do fitness from home
a lot of gyms across the country are
simply not open because the government
thinks that these are vectors of
transmission whatever the evidence
that is simply the case well the reality
is you still need to work out at home
but you've been looking at some of these
programs like for example peloton and
you're like that costs a damned fortune
and it does i mean peloton is so
expensive
i looked at it for my wife and for me i
was gonna be one of those husbands who
got his wife a peloton bike and i looked
at the price i went
nope that is way too expensive well
thankfully for me there is something
else out there i'm talking about echelon
echelon has a huge lineup of connected
fitness bikes fitness mirrors rowing
machines that give you a fun
challenging workout for the comfort and
safety of your home i'm getting an
echelon bike i could not be more pumped
about this
it's connected into all of the classes
the same way that other services are
except it's not going to cost you an arm
and a leg you don't actually have to
sell a body part in order to make sure
that you stay in shape in as little as
20 minutes you can get into the best
shape of your life and be active with
the entire family
the world-class instructors will
motivate you with daily live and
on-demand classes that are always
available
when you need them and unlike their
competitors echelon is affordable for
everyone their ex1 connected fitness
bike is less than half
the price of a peloton which is pretty
spectacular because all the peloton is
is just an exercise bike hooked up
to a bunch of classes well echelon is
cutting out the middleman and echelon is
ensuring that you're not going to have
to pay a fortune
for basically the same or better service
with echelon financing you can try them
out risk-free for 30 days
zero down as little as 46 bucks per
month don't pay a ton for a peloton no
reason for that go to echelonfit.com
that's echelon e c
h e l o n fit.com echelonfit.com
go check them out right now i couldn't
be more enthused about getting one of
these for myself and for my wife
echelon fit.com ben go check them out
right now okay so that was gaff number
one that made a lot of headlines
yesterday gaffe number two
is trump pronouncing thailand the
country thailand
so he corrects himself pretty much
immediately it doesn't matter this is
the
the gaff that spawns a thousand memes
because it's funny i mean let's face it
calling thailand thailand is kind of
hilarious so here's the president
yesterday
shortly after so uh first of all i want
where in the world is donald trump and
it's like where in the world
is donald j trump is carmen sandy i just
want to hear him pronounce country names
i'm just i'm very into it right now i i
will admit that between
yes i might and also thailand it's
it's fun here's president from gaffing
on thailand yesterday
in 2017 whirlpool won relief from the
itc once again
once more your foreign competitors moved
their factories to prevent a level
playing field and to avoid liability
shifting production to thailand and to
vietnam
thailand and vietnam to places that
i like their leaders very much they're
very nice to us
do they take advantage of the united
states but not so much anymore
like he corrects it right away my three
favorite countries thailand
china jubilee and and i will admit
thailand sounds a lot more fun than
thailand
it does and i i it sounds frankly kind
of like a strip club in kansas city
thailand hey a thousand beautiful women
in one ugly one right and donald trump
out front holding one of those weird
signs and spinning it
thailand come right in thailand it's
amazing right down in the center of
thailand it's where the stage is
thailand but
okay so it makes for good comedy but is
that like a revealing gap no
you just mispronounced thailand like who
cares who cares that didn't stop people
online there was like a big argument
last night on twitter
about the proper pronunciation of
thailand because everything is stupid
everything's unbelievably stupid so
dinesh de souza who i like i mean i like
dinesh but dinesh did like a whole
thread about how
the proper way to pronounce thailand is
thailand if you're australian
or british so i actually looked up boris
johnson saying thailand and he says
thailand he doesn't say thailand just
for the record but
with all of that said is that like a
revealing gaff of course that's not a
revealing gaffe
unless you're revealing a thigh in
thailand but is that like a super
revealing gaff
of course that's not a revealing gap
it's just silly because it's funny and
it's silly and makes for good late night
political comedy
and that's pretty much it stormy daniels
performing in thailand
unbelievable karen mcdouga but again
the media covered this thing like wall
the wall yesterday it was like a
wall-to-wall coverage
in the media yesterday so again we're
getting all of these quote-unquote
gaffes from trump and they're basically
innocuous or mild exaggerations or like
none of these
are world shaking in their in their
import
and we saw the same thing over the past
48 hours 72 hours
after trump did that interview with
jonathan swan there were some real
mistakes in that interview i talked
about them on monday's show
but one of those things that he said is
he was talking about the levels of death
in the united states and he said it is
what it is meaning i can't control how
many people buy from a disease which
is true and reporters have been all over
them for that how could he say it is
what it is what's he supposed to say it
is what it isn't
i mean when he when a disease is running
rampant through a community and you're
doing the best you can
like he should have expressed more
sympathy so it's a political gaffe in
that way i suppose it reveals that
he has a lack of empathy if if that's a
thing that you think is super important
but
and and i guess it's important but but
you know when he says it is what it is
and that's treated like a major story
it's still being treated like a major
story like five days later here's a
reporter yesterday going after trump
over that yesterday
he said that's true and it is what it is
you use the words it is what it is is
that the message
you look at the statement i made right
after that because if you look at what
it is but that doesn't
mean we aren't doing everything we can
yeah and i said something after that too
so so the message that i have is very
simple
nobody can do what i've done in terms of
all of the things that
we're doing to uh combat this
horrible disease that never should have
been sent to us
okay so he he's not wrong about any of
this but the media covered this stuff
wall-to-wall the reason that i'm
focusing in on this
is because this is what trump is up
against he'll make a fairly innocuous
gaffe and the media will blow it all out
of proportion meanwhile
joe biden will make gaffes that go
directly to the heart of his campaign
and the media will simply
overlook them and just completely
overlook them we'll get to joe biden's
gaffes in just one second cause take
gaffe a minute around here
again these debates are going to be as
i've said before the swedish chef versus
chewbacca it's just going to be trump
going
and joe biden going heard the best spin
the moon
and setting himself on fire i mean
that's it'll be fun
i guess if that's your thing it's kind
of my thing it's going to be fun we'll
get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that hiring can be
complicated particularly
these days and that is why quotable
co-founder gretchen hebner
had to experience how challenging hiring
can be and used zipper crew she switched
to zip recruiter she saw an immediate
difference
in trying to find a new game artist to
grow with her education tech company
you can too by signing up for free at
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire zip recruiter does not depend
on candidates finding you it finds them
for you by using zip recruiters
screening questions to filter candidates
gretchen found it easier to focus on the
best ones and then find the right one
in fact after posting her job on zip
recruiter gretchen said she was honestly
surprised she found qualified applicants
so quickly and hired a new game artist
in less than two weeks with results like
that it is no wonder that four out of
five employers who post unzip recruiter
get a quality candidate within
the very first day so for example
you know we have a producer here katie
and katie has decided that she actually
wants to help children instead of
being here and helping me put together
clips in the morning i don't know what's
going through her head but we need to
replace katie we do
and that means that we have been using
zip recruiter right now to try zip
recruiter for free you can go to
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that's ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e-recruiter.com
dailywire helps prospective employees
and prospective employers connect
quickly
and easily zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire go check them out
right now ziprecruiter.com
dailywire to try them out for free okay
so meanwhile joe biden again
making gas that actually go to the heart
of his campaign so yesterday
joe biden suggested that black people
are not diverse like latino people and
again he has said this like repeatedly
okay they're treating this as though
this was a weird outlier that he was
just a brain fart from
from biden and let's be real that man
has a very flatulent brain there
there's a lot of farts coming out of
that brain a lot of brain farts and
it could enough methane to choke a horse
in any case
this was not a brain fart this is
something that biden has been saying
repeatedly for years which is that black
people all think the same according to
joe biden
he said it again just a few weeks ago
when he suggested they aim black if you
don't vote for joe biden
and then he said it a couple of days ago
to the national association of black
journalists
when he suggested that black people
aren't diverse like latino people
which is a very weird take i mean
and kind of a racist take that your skin
color defines how you vote by the way he
doubled down on this yesterday
like there was a second clip of him
saying exactly the same thing later in
the day
it never went around because the media
wanted to pretend that this is a brain
fart rather than
a key component of his entire campaign
he later
that day he said it again he said black
community does not think in diverse
fashion
as opposed to latino community coming
from all different places a lot of
diversity within the latino community
which is wild i will acknowledge that
members of the media actually kind of
agree with joe biden they do this is why
they speak of the black community as a
monolith
it's also why the the media have overtly
stated
that black should be capitalized in
media coverage while white should not be
because
black people are not diverse they share
a common history which is a weird thing
because africa is incredibly diverse
black americans don't have a ton in
common i mean they're most black
americans
are centuries removed from africa i mean
they're african-americans their
ancestors of ancestors came
from africa not voluntarily obviously to
the united states
the black community is incredibly
diverse but the line of the media is
that all black people are basically the
same and joe biden mirrors that here he
was a couple of days ago saying that
what you all know but most people don't
know unlike the african-american
community with notable exceptions
the latino community is an incredibly
diverse community
with incredibly different attitudes
about different things
unlike the black community where
everybody thinks the same thanks old joe
okay so he then doubled down on that
later in the day and
nobody paid attention to it and then he
came out and so the entire media went
into full spin mode the washington post
had a fact check
in which they suggested that joe biden
had not said what he said not kidding
they did a full fact check because trump
said
he's saying all black people think alike
and the washington post was like he
didn't say that
he just meant like in terms of point of
origin which of course is not what he
said at all
and then joe biden stepped on them he
put out a statement via twitter saying
early today
i made some comments about diversity in
the african-american and latino
communities that i want to clarify
in no way did i mean to suggest the
african-american community is a monolith
not by identity not on issues not at all
throughout my career i've witnessed the
diversity of thought background and
sentiment within the african-american
community it's this diversity that makes
our workplaces communities and country
a better place my commitment to you is
this i will always listen
i will never stop fighting for the
african-american community i will never
stop fighting for a more equitable
future and then he put out an ad with
john lewis which is like his get out of
jail free card
is that he was friendly with john lewis
so okay
he that's absolutely what he said and he
has said it repeatedly that he thinks
that all black people think the same
okay that's
that is not the gaffe is revealing
because again the gaffe strips away the
veneer
of joe biden thinks of black people as
individuals he doesn't really okay so
how did the media cover this
so we've talked about how the media
covered thailand how the media covered
her god how did how did the media cover
joe biden saying all black people think
the same
listen to the headlines it wasn't that
they covered the original biden comments
accurately and then provided cover when
biden backtracked
they didn't even cover the original
headline accurately
they didn't like here was politico's
headline about that comment right the
one where he says that all black people
think the same
politico's headline was this quote joe
biden contrasted the black and latino
communities and remarks on wednesday
stating that the latter is incredibly
diverse oh is that the story
is that the story that he like that that
headline is designed to not convey
information
you can tell when the media are covering
for somebody when the media decides to
cover
the story in such a way that you have
less information from the headline than
you would listening to the original
quote
that is a that is a headline
deliberately designed to obscure
information
joe biden contrasted the black and
latino communities in remarks on
wednesday
so that sounds like i mean that's
completely innocuous right i mean just
he contrasted them
and then they didn't focus in on what
the what he said about the black
community which is that they are not
diverse
they focus in on him saying the latino
community is diverse so if you read that
headline you would come away with oh
that sounds uncontroversial
i mean that's an incredible headline an
incredible headline and the media
response to this is
patently crazy i mean joe scarborough
said on msnbc here's how scarborough
covered it quote
biden made that argument in artfully he
didn't need to include the
african-american community in the
discussion
but he does seem to recognize the latino
community is not one giant monolithic
community
so by putting the focus on what he said
about latinos you completely ignore what
he said about african americans
that's that's the goal of the media
coverage here okay on cnn
in on cnn the chiron as they were
discussing this issue is not biden
insults black community as monolithic
the chiron was a direct quote this
direct quote from cnn chiron
trump claims biden insulted black
community oh trump claimed it
you see the real story is republicans
pouncing as always when a democrat does
something bad as my friend andrew clavin
points out the story is republicans
pouncing when republicans do something
bad
the stories republicans did something
bad in fact even when republicans don't
do something bad the story is
republicans
did something bad it's amazing here was
the associated press's headline on this
you ready
democratic presidential candidate joe
biden faces new scrutiny over how he
discusses race and ethnicity
after drawing distinctions between black
and hispanic populations in the united
states
oh is that what happened he just drew
some distinctions guys
and the stories that he drew scrutiny
you see the story is republicans
pouncing
it's the scrutiny that's the story not
the fact that he said that black people
are not diverse but latino people are
diverse
no the story is everybody pouncing
that's the big story
i mean the media are so far in the tank
for biden it is
i know that it's an old news thing at
this point but it is a constant source
of astonishment that they are so willing
to bend over backwards
in order to in order to push this agenda
it's it's
really incredible it truly is amazing
and meanwhile joe biden continues to
gaff on policy again his gaps on policy
are pretty telling because they explain
where he's going to be so yesterday joe
biden was asked about his policy on
china how he was going to stop china
from engaging in intellectual property
theft and threatening its neighbors his
assets by errol barnett his answer was
i'm going to go to the un
which in any normal world would be a
headline because
china has a veto at the un okay china is
never going to allow anything to happen
at the u.n saying you're going to go to
the un to stop china
is like saying that you are going to go
to al capone to stop bootlegging
that's not the way this works here is
joe biden saying a stupid thing as
always
you may recall i was the first one to
say
we should act and go to the united
nations with the uyghurs
i believe the first one period we should
be in the united nations condemning
china's action their concentration camps
they're concentration camps you mean
you're going to go to the u.n and you're
going to get a resolution
where from the security council where
china sits i'm sure that's going to
that's going to go
wow a resolution from the u.n huge
like enormous enormous joe biden and
he's the one he says he's tough on china
yeah i think not how is that not a
headline
that he thinks that he's going to go to
the u.n and condemn them at the u.n
like joe biden's camp at a certain point
he's actually going to be forced to
answer questions about his own policies
so far he has not been forced to do so
because the media despised trump so much
that every trumpian error is treated as
the end of the world and every biden
error is treated as nothing
literally nothing just turned into a
non-story
and that's it's no wonder if the
american people never see the actual
story
if they never see the actual clips it's
no wonder that they think that joe biden
is a lot more stable than he is he is
not a stable candidate he's not stable
in terms of policy he's not stable
in terms of his his mental state the
more you see
if this were an open campaign this race
would be a lot closer because joe biden
on the campaign trail would be gaffing
like that every 35 seconds
every 35 seconds not just the sort of
mental acuity issues that he's been
having
but simple statements that would be
eating him alive
i mean he was always like this guys i
mean he went go back to like his
campaign in 2008
he was going around a decade ago a
decade and a half ago
saying that indian people run 7-elevens
as though the only indian person he'd
ever met was a poo from the simpsons
this is who joe biden is the fact that
he's considered a front-line
solid presidential candidate
demonstrates how stupid everything is at
this point okay in a second we're gonna
get to how democrats are twisting
coveted policy because again
the trump campaign is is basically
behind the eight ball on covet and
democrats are going to keep pushing that
and they're rooting for lockdown they're
rooting for lockdown and economic ruin i
don't know how else to express this
i'm going to show you the proof of that
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact
that there are some cases that are
happening right now in the united states
where if you defend your own property
with a gun
there is a likelihood that you will be
dragged into court we actually saw this
in missouri
when two property owners went out there
in the middle of what was going to be a
riot people broke into a private gated
community
they went out there and they held up
guns to basically say
you're not coming into our property and
the local prosecutor in st louis tried
to prosecute them for that
well the uscca can help protect you from
stuff like this the legal system is not
fair responsibly armed americans often
do become political targets
it is not right that responsible
americans can wind up in jail or tied up
in a lawsuit for defending themselves or
their family but in this day and age you
need a gun to protect your family and
yourself
here's how you can take a simple
powerful journey to firearms and
self-defense confidence it's called the
complete concealed carry and family
defense guide
from the u.s concealed carry association
it is 100 free
you'll learn how to detect attackers
before they see you how to survive a
mass shooting
the safest most dangerous places to sit
in a restaurant how to responsibly own
and store a gun even if you have little
kids especially if you have little kids
a whole lot more it's 164 pages it comes
with a bonus audio version so you can
listen whenever you want
yeah if it's important right now i mean
more than any time i can remember to own
a firearm so you can defend yourself
your family your rights
but you got to know how to use it
responsibly and store it responsibly
uscca helps you with all of this stuff
just text ben
28722 to get started you get instant
access and a chance to win a thousand
bucks so you can buy a gun to protect
your family
text ben to 87 222 right now and join
the uscca
text ben to 87 222 right this very
instant okay so
one of the democratic policy pushes here
is
additional chaos when it comes to covid
so one of the things that is is really
in the offing here
is a significant economic recovery
the united states economy added 1.8
million jobs in july
unemployment fell to 10 percent this is
despite the fact that we are now
widely locked down continuing across the
united states
now the economy is still locked down in
california it is still locked down in
new york
many of the major economic hubs of the
united states continue to be locked down
the economy is basically attempting to
to break free right here i mean that is
what is going on
and the only thing that is preventing
the economy from breaking fear two
things one fear of covet some of which
is legit and some of which is
wildly exaggerated it is my opinion that
if you are young and healthy
and you're wearing a mask around other
people when you're in crowded areas and
you're socially distancing for the most
part you can go back to work and you
should be going back to work
and we should all be going back to the
stores we should all be going back to
the restaurants you can have
half occupancy or whatever you need to
do keep the windows open but we should
all be moving back toward normal
and this notion that lockdowns are the
solution is not correct
meanwhile democrats continue to push
continuing lockdown
now continuing lockdown all the lockdown
does is it delays the inevitable
if you look at hawaii right now hawaii
has never opened up hawaii has been
locked down the entire time they're
seeing exponential growth
in case numbers in hawaii they're seeing
increases in france they're seeing
increases in japan they're seeing
increases in australia
all the places that lock down all the
places that have worn masks
many of them are starting to see
outbreaks the bottom line is you can
only delay the virus you cannot prevent
the virus from moving through a
population which means
that you need to protect the elderly you
need to protect the infirm you need to
protect those with serious pre-existing
conditions and everybody else
needs to get back to work with as many
precautions as we can take
and still live normal lives none of this
should be particularly controversial
and the economy is waiting to break
loose if the economy starts to break
loose again the problem for democrats is
there's a better shot that trump is
going to win it's hard not to see this
in extraordinarily political light
joe biden keeps saying that he wants
more lockdown so yesterday joe biden
came out
he said that if he were president he
would bring back the coveted lockdowns
which is patently crazy
it's crazy where is he going to bring
them back new york they never stop being
locked down
in new york and new york's caseload is
basically zero at this point
new jersey has a close to zero case load
in places where they did lock down and
never stop the lockdown in massachusetts
they're seeing an uptick anyway
lockdowns are not a solution
all lockdowns are our delay tactics here
is joe biden though saying that his easy
solution would be to continue to lock
down the american economy forever
again the political incentive structure
here is completely screwy
the political incentive structure is for
politicians to deliberately destroy
individual lives
and then bail people out through bucks
that we do not have
in order to say that they are protecting
you which is totally
it's crazy i mean they're destroying
thousands upon thousands of individual
businesses
every single month here is joe biden
though promoting lockdown again
so based on what you see now would you
roll back the reopenings
i'm not going to speculate on that
because i don't know
what i see now i think we are if our
president oh i'm sorry
if our president today i would roll back
the reopenings in a number of places
because look
mascara it's clear mask and social
distancing
make a gigantic difference in terms of
the spread of
this disease he would roll back
openings in which places would be
rolling back florida texas
arizona they're already seeing the
downshift where are the reopenings that
he's talking about
okay none of this makes any sense but
the political incentive structure is
aligned
so you push the lockdowns you claim
you're trying to save lives and oh by
the way if it ruins the economy and then
we need massive government bailouts
great
the second problem of this attack is
being promoted by nancy pelosi so right
now republicans have basically agreed
with democrats that we are going to
spend an awful lot of money because we
are forcing people into bankruptcy we
are forcing people into lockdown
and if you can't work then you can't
make money and so republicans
for the first time in my lifetime
basically in widespread fashion
agree that some sort of government
intervention is necessary in the economy
in order to ensure that people don't go
completely without
so that means that the republicans were
willing to basically extend in clean
fashion unemployment insurance for a
couple more months at 600
per week originally they proposed a
couple hundred bucks a week because they
don't want to pay people to stay home
it turns out that if we pay everybody
through january 600
a week four out of five american workers
would actually be making more
i believe the statistic was four out of
five american workers currently
unemployed would be making more on
unemployment
than they would be if they went back to
work if you continue this through
january
democrats are pushing for that democrats
are also pushing for spending on every
area of american life they want 3.4
trillion
more dollars spent this month by the way
they have not even fully spent all the
money that was sent to the states in the
last
tranche of spending and republicans are
going along with all this
republicans have caved on a lot of the
state and local funding which they
should not the federal government is not
responsible for bailing out crappy
government contracts created by
california and new york
the republicans have basically caved on
the
on the unemployment money when the
states have not even fully dispersed
their unemployment money yet i know
people in california
who have filed for unemployment in
california still not receive their
checks from the last tranche
but republicans are caving left and
right because steve mnuchin the treasury
secretary
is not a republican so he's he's out
there being like okay fine nancy what do
you want
you want this sure we'll give it to you
you want that sure we'll give it to you
and nancy pelosi because her political
interest is in not getting a deal done
so she can blame trump
is still holding up the works this is
the second or third time she's done this
remember on the first round of relief
nancy pelosi stopped a deal that had
already been cut between the senate
majority leader and the senate minority
leader mitch mcconnell
and chuck schumer so that she could
dilly tally for a week
for a week and she said that she was
trying to make the deal better she'd
make the deal better it ended up exactly
where it started now nancy pelosi is
doing the same thing she's negotiating
against no one
because no one's actually pushing back
against her the only concession
democrats have offered thus far
is that they want to spend slightly less
on the post office that's it that's the
only concession
republicans have conceded on nearly
every other point and nancy pelosi is
still trying to gum up the works
so nancy pelosi was asked about this by
judy woodruff okay now
let's be clear about this judy woodruff
who works for what uh pbs news
so judy woodruff is no right winger when
i say she's no right winger i mean judy
woodruff is a leftist okay she's been a
liberal journalist for a very long time
and judy woodruff asked like a very
basic question to pelosi and pelosi
doesn't want to be
asked that question because it
demonstrates that she is a full-scale
political actor who would prefer to
watch americans go without
rather than letting trump take credit
for preventing
people from going under i mean this is
very nasty politics it's so much that
nancy pelosi goes after judy woodruff
and suggests that judy woodruff is
basically a republican which is patently
crazy
here's here's judy woodruff asking a
basic question and nancy pelosi dentures
all falling out
trying to explain that judy woodruff is
a bad person for even asking
and they're also saying a lot of the
money that was passed in the spring
madam speaker
has not even been spent yet well so you
want to be an
advocate for them judy if you want to be
an advocate for them no i'm that's why
what the i'm playing devil's
advocate no
no i'm going to ask you for your
position okay again and she doesn't want
to give the position
she simply doesn't want to give the
position because the position is obvious
she doesn't want the relief package to
move forward because if a relief
package it if a relief package moves
forward
then she doesn't get to claim that
republicans are obstructing
she's the one who's obstructing again
this is like the third time she's done
this i think she did it again with the
second package
so it's pretty obvious the democratic
game push lockdown
and then try to block republicans from
filling in the gaps created
by lockdown and then finally there's an
overarching change the democrats are
pushing here
every crisis is an opportunity michelle
obama yesterday said the quiet part out
loud we'll get to michelle obama who's
becoming more and more political have
you noticed have you noticed that
michelle obama
she started off her career being
extremely political barack's going to
heal your souls i've never been proud of
this country until the moment they
nominated my husband
and she was very radical back in her
early days i mean her college thesis was
extraordinarily radical about
the the inherent racism of the united
states i believe it was about when she
was at princeton
and then she went into michelle about
she kind of did the hillary clinton
makeover right hillary clinton back when
she was first lady she started off
i'm not tammy wynette stay at home stay
by her man and then she went into kind
of the softer version of hillary clinton
where she stood by her man
and then she went back into harsh
politician you get the same thing with
michelle obama we'll get to that in
just one second the the re the repo
politicization of michelle obama we'll
get to that
momentarily first let's talk about how
important it is to protect your online
data
pcmatic it's a next generation antivirus
designed to stop modern threats like
ransomware an independent testing from
av test just named pcmatic as a top
performer
in the cyber security industry giving it
the best performance award for 2019.
only pcmatic has american research
development and support pcmatic
competition is foreign made
often in countries where malware
originates pcmatic blocks annoying and
malicious ads for hassle-free web
browsing makes your computers
faster and more reliable even after
years of use pcmatic protects windows
computers including
xp vista windows 7 8 and 10 windows
servers max macbooks android phones and
tablets listen you got to protect your
information
people out there are trying to steal it
they're trying to use it they're trying
to data mine you
pcmatic is just 50 bucks for five
devices for one year
with a full 30 day money back guarantee
if you act now pcmatic has offered my
listeners a free month on security
protection
with the purchase of the annual license
to access the offer go to pcmatic.com
again to get world-class security that
keeps your computer running great
go to pcmatic.com again that is
pcmatic.com
go check them out right now special deal
50 bucks for five devices one year
full 30 day money back guarantee
pcmatic.com to protect
your online data okay it is that
glorious time
of the week when i give a shout out to a
daily wire member it is that time
okay today it is mateo on instagram who
understands the power of narrative
in this picture the world's greatest
beverage vessel rests on a table next to
a copy of my brand new best-selling book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps
the caption reads after i completed
reading the book which fully debunks the
ideology of the left with nothing but
facts which specifically do not care
about your feelings
i found it necessary and correct to
enjoy a cup of black rifle coffee as i
gazed into my cupboard one vessel shown
above the others
it was the most elite beverage vessel of
them all a tumbler unlike any other it
was the leftist tears tumbler the choice
was clear i knew what must be done as i
poured the rich dark caffeinated nectar
i looked to my window to behold an
awesome sight a bearded man mounted upon
a bald eagle had flown across my
neighborhood
in one hand he held the bible and the
other was old glory could it be old abe
himself
i thought as i continued to pour my
luscious beverage i can only assume it
was the sheer level of patriotism
accomplished this day that drew him to
pass by as the first sip of coffee hit
my lips i saw red white and blue
fireworks on the horizon i heard in the
distance the melody of the
cyrus bengal banner and breathed in the
aroma of pure freedom
thank you official ben shapiro wow
wow that's beautiful i'm gonna cry well
done
my friend that is just that's amazing
also pros stylings
the like of which we have not seen since
hemingway ernest hemingway thanks for
the pick
i hope that you are enjoying the book
which by the way is number three on the
wall street journal bestseller list
again this week so thanks for that if
you haven't picked up a copy of the book
go do it right now
how to destroy america in three easy
steps you're listening to the largest
fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so michelle obama who has
become more and more political like a
couple of weeks ago she did a graduation
speech in which she claimed
that you cannot get ahead like you
literally it's impossible people in the
united states
simply cannot get ahead her direct quote
i believe
was quote the truth is when it comes to
all those tidy stories of hard work and
self-determination
we like to tell ourselves about america
well the reality is a lot more
complicated than that said michelle
obama there's a couple weeks ago for too
many people in this country no matter
how hard they work there are structural
barriers working against them that just
make the road longer and rockier
sometimes it's impossible to move upward
at all and that is a very political
statement from a woman
who again grew up kind of middle class
her dad was a city worker her mom was a
homemaker
and then she ended up at princeton at
harvard law school ended up working at a
law firm making a bunch of money
married the president of the future
president of the united states is now
probably the best-selling non-fiction
author of the last 20 years
seems like there's been some upward
mobility in her life seems like there's
an upward mobility in a lot of our lives
but michelle obama is a very political
figure if you believe she will not run
for president at some point in the
future
i think you have another thing coming in
any case michelle obama completes the
trifecta of
of coronavirus policy here so remember
when it comes to the democrats
they have to rely on kovid to bring
trump down
i mean i think that that is what's going
on here i used to think there's some
good faith i i no longer think that
because
good faith would assume some basic
premises about coronavirus one there's
no great way to handle it
two everybody is doing their best to
prevent loss of life and prevent loss of
the economy
and three to blame any single person for
a disease that no country has control
over is insane but democrats have
decided to ignore all of these things
and now they are openly militating for
policy that has not been successful
they're suggesting that places that are
utterly unsuccessful are successful like
new jersey and new york
and they're pretending that they have
all the solutions so they've come up
with this sort of three-pronged attack
one is joe biden's lockdowns two is
nancy pelosi's
i'm going to block any of the funding
necessary to stop the worst of the
fallout so i can blame republicans
and three santa voce we are hoping that
this completely reshifts the nature of
american government that's what michelle
obama said yesterday
she said kovid is a great opportunity to
change how wealth is distributed
which is insane insane if coveted has
done anything it has shifted more wealth
toward the wealthier
okay let's be real about this if you are
a high net income person in the united
states
chances are you're probably still
working right now if you're a white
collar worker a lot better shot that you
are working than if you're a blue collar
worker
low income people have been thrown out
of work that is what has happened
people who have money in the stock
market are doing basically okay because
you know what all the rich people did
they didn't sell their stocks when the
stock market crashed they just bought
everybody else's stock when those people
had to liquidate their stock in order to
pay their bills
coronavirus has exacerbated income
inequality in this country
and that is government driven a lot of
that is government driven but michelle
obama says
covet's a great opportunity because
every crisis is an opportunity for
democrats michelle obama said kova is a
great opportunity to change how wealth
is distributed in the united states
that's the real agenda
here that's a part of that reflection
that we need to do you know
with ourselves and and as a community
and we have to think about that in terms
of
how uh wealth is distributed
you know how how these essential people
are supported
and what does that mean a lot of these
people
are broke okay uh
the the amazing attempt here to to
shift the entire american conversation
around an unprecedented
pandemic no one has full control over
and to turn that into we have to have a
conversation
about completely reshifting the nature
of american government that's
opportunism
at its finest and so that's the
democratic platform shut it all down
try to block republicans from doing
anything to stop that and then
say that we need to reshift the entire
american economy it is
fairly incredible how so many people
fall for this it really is
you know every time government fails the
solution is always more government it's
an unfalsifiable theory
the government has forcibly shut down
millions of businesses
all around the united states the
government has put
tens of millions of people out of work
and then the government has
incompetently attempted to backfill some
of that
and the solution from the democrats is
more government
if you fall for that one you kind of
deserve what you get i mean frankly if
you fall for the idea that government is
going to fix all the problems that
government helped create in the first
place
and you don't think that individual
initiative and self
assessment and a realistic appraisal of
your own situation is the best answer
then you deserve to be controlled from
above i don't know what else to tell you
okay meanwhile over in new york you know
if you've ever
it's amazing how many people in the
media have declared that republicans are
fascists right trump is a fascist trump
is a
he's a bad bad orange man he's orange
hitler and all the rest of this stuff
what is the evidence for trump being a
fascist he tweets things he tweets
stupid things like he wants to delay the
election
which is indeed a silly and fascistic
thing to say it is not he does not have
the power to delay the election
to pretend otherwise he is ridiculous
and undermines faith in our democratic
institutions
meanwhile democrats are overtly
violating certain
requirements that we normally have of of
people in public life
so over in new york leticia james is the
new york attorney general she's now
attempting to dissolve the nra now
here's the thing
she said for a while she just wants to
go after the nra she called the nra a
terrorist group
a couple of years ago when she first
took office as a.g
she vowed openly to target trump she
also by the way vowed to target the nra
so this is pure political targeting
couple things can be true one there can
be serious real
corruption problems over the nra and two
when the new york ag decides to dissolve
the nra that has nothing to do with the
corruption problems and everything to do
with this particular ag using the power
of her office to target political
opponents
here was latisha james announcing a
lawsuit to dissolve the nra yesterday
just a few minutes ago my office filed a
lawsuit against the national rifle
association
to dissolve the organization in its
entirety
for years of self-dealing and illegal
conduct
that violate new york's charities law
and undermine its own mission and now
the real reason she's doing this is
because there's a widespread perception
in democratic circles
that the nra spends tons and tons of
money during election cycles they don't
they spend like 18 20 million dollars
during a normal presidential election
cycle as compared to like michael
bloomberg who will drop a hundred
million dollars
in an election cycle himself alone okay
but
let's be real about this latisha james
said when she took office that she was
going to specifically target trump
which is a violation of a prosecutorial
duty normally you hunt for a crime you
don't hunt for somebody you don't like
and then try and pin a crime on them
here's a flashback of letitia james
vowing to target trump when she took
office
never be afraid to challenge this
illegitimate president what is fueling
my soul right now is trump and his
abuses
abuses against immigrants against women
against our environment
we must do our job to ensure that the
man
currently occupying the oval office
is held accountable to any and
everything he has done
i mean that's it if you want to talk
about fascism fascism is electing
a dea specifically arguing they're going
to go after a person they have not
identified a crime about
i mean that's pretty incredible to tar
so she said that about trump she also
said similar things about the nra
and now she's going after the nra and
the media are just cheering the media
are like oh look
hero hero time for latisha james if that
doesn't scare you i really
do not know what would and if democrats
love this sort of stuff wait until
republican agents start doing the same
thing going after planned parenthood and
attempting to dissolve planned
parenthood on a state-by-state basis
saying that there are corruption issues
inside planned parenthood the death
penalty remedy as the wall street
journal put it
right it's death penalty remedy to
dissolve the entire organization she's
not going after wayne lapierre
she's not going after the other members
of the board she's trying to dissolve
the organization utterly
that's a pretty it's a pretty clear
indicator that she is giving the game
away president trump for his part says
i don't even know why the nra is
organized in new york they should move
to texas
that's a very terrible thing that just
happened
i think the nra should move to texas
and lead a very good and beautiful life
and i've told them that for a long time
i think they should
move to texas texas would be a great
place or to another state
of their choosing but i would say that
texas would be a great place in an
appropriate place for the nra
okay he ain't wrong about this that is
for sure okay meanwhile
i have to discuss this bizarre
controversy that broke out online it
wasn't covered as much as it should be
because it truly is indicative of where
we stand
in american public life we now live in a
time
when power politics is significantly
more important than truth and you can
see this from both sides of the aisle
but
i will say that the deconstructionist
wing of the democratic party the radical
wing of the democratic party the sort of
the the sort of social justice warrior
critical race studies
wing of the democratic party has really
decided to prioritize
power structures and power dynamics over
truth this is why you see people
suggesting
that any inequality is inequity it's why
you see people completely ignoring
statistics
in order to push a narrative because in
the end all that matters is power
the story that brought this to a head
was this bizarre
bizarre debate that happened last
weekend on twitter over whether i kid
you not two plus two equals four
now i know what you're saying to
yourself doesn't two plus two equal four
why is that controversial
the answer is because if you live in the
world of critical race theory if you
live in the world
of darada and michel foucault and their
philosophy of deconstructionism
then all truth is subjective there is no
such thing as an object of truth so two
plus two could theoretically equal five
there's a professor named james lindsey
and all of this controversy started
when he had a text exchange with another
person
about post-modernism and what they think
about objective claims
about the world his friend asked him at
one point what post-modernists would say
about the contention that two plus two
equals four
and and this professor james lindsay
who's a professor professor of
mathematics
he says i told her that they would say
the two plus two does not equal five
they would say two plus two equals
doesn't matter so long as what it equals
is not constrained by hegemonic
discourses meaning that two plus two
could equal five it could not equal five
it all depends on what the westerners
say if the westerners say two plus two
equals four that is now
an intellectual construct that must be
torn down at the root
so says james lindsey the post-modern
understanding of two plus two can equal
whatever people want it to equal
and we should be very skeptical of the
idea that it equals four because so much
political dominance
is already built into that answer and
how it is obtained that answer
is basic post-modernism and it has
infused so much
of wild left-wing thought well what
happened here
is that nicole hannah jones who's the de
facto editor of the new york times
she decided to make fun of the idea that
two plus two equals
four saying using arabic numerals to try
to make a point about white western
superiority is just so damn classic
which is kind of crazy right okay so
the the content what was happening is
that somebody said two plus two
equals four and then somebody else
tweeted back well according to
deconstruction as two plus two could
equal five because
math is just a western construct and
then nicole hannah jones because she's a
crazy person
tweeted back using arabic numerals to
try to make a point about white western
superiority is just so damn classic
no there's nothing white western or
superior about the contention that two
plus two equals four but
if you see the world purely in terms of
power structures then everything that is
ever said is merely a manifestation
of power it's merely a manifestation of
power
and so when people came forth to defend
the proposition that two plus two does
objectively equal four
a bunch of randos in the academic
community
began tweeting out the idea that two
plus two does not in fact equal four
a phd student named brittany marshall
insisted quote
the idea of two plus two equaling four
is cultural and because of western
imperialism and colonization
we think of it as the only way of
knowing now we've seen stuff like this
actually being taught at like the
smithsonian institute that the basic
idea of science or math is a western
construct
that is the most racist garbage ever but
if the idea is that all
knowledge is merely a manifestation of
the peculiar minds of the power
structure
then it means that truth is of no
consequence whatsoever anything can be
not true so long as it is said by a
white person or is a manifestation of
the white power structure
and so in politics truth doesn't matter
the objective truth of a statement
doesn't exist it is just a bunch of
white people saying something
this is why you see so many people in
the critical justice the critical race
studies program the critical race theory
the abram kennedys and the robin
d'angelo
basically say that objective truth
doesn't exist anything that i want to be
is
and if you deny it it's because you're a
racist who assumes cultural superiority
this is dangerous stuff it's this little
controversy which completely blew up
over the weekend i mean two plus two
equals four is actually trending on
twitter
this is how far we have come as a
civilization to deny basic truth
in exchange for the principle that all
truth is basically subjective
and is replaceable by power structures
and so we have to shift away from
the notion that we can have i mean all
conversation ends at this point it's
just a question of
certain people clubbing other people to
death politically and intellectually
speaking
alrighty so we'll be back here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of content also i am doing a late
breaking all access today so if you want
to become an all-access member head on
over to daily wear i believe we have
some deals
over there for our all access members
also as you approach the weekend please
pick up a copy of my book how to destroy
america in three easy steps continues to
be a massive national
bestseller and we always appreciate you
joining in i think the book is really
really important and i think that you'll
get something out of it i think you
should buy one for your liberal friends
too because it really is not about left
versus right so much as
people who want to keep the country
together versus people who would like to
break the country
apart so go check out a copy of my book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps otherwise we'll see you here
on monday i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producer mathis glover and
robert sterling assistant director pablo
wydowski
technical producer austin stevens
playback and media operated by nick
sheehan
associate producer katie swinerton
edited by adam syavets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses
are life family faith
those are fundamental and that's what
this show is about i hope you'll
give it a listen
you